We. Are at War
We'll annihilate everything.
The champions of this realm can do
nothing to stop us.
You are very menacing.
I just want you to know that
a lot has changed in the last few years.
A wizard gave me superpowers.
The daughters of Atlas
are coming to hunt us.
Children stole the power of the gods,
ripped it from our fathers. Cool.
But I feel like maybe
I should be writing all this down.
Give us the powers, child.
Your world will not survive this.
You want these powers?
Come get them
khaleesi
we have one job to do. Save the world.
Billy
I don't know how we fight
powers like this.
I can't do this.
Take my powers back.
You came to me
so you would take them back right?
I spent a millenia
cearching for word to champion.
You know what must be done.
Really?
What are you doing?
I have to do this.
We end this now.
Yeah, we do.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We'll do an IMAX ticket
giveaway for the movie.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and just post your favorite moment
from the trailer on the video.
The big thing in this new trailer is
we learn a little bit
more about the actual story.
So the whole idea is that
the three daughters of the Titan
Atlas, the Greek titan,
because we're talking about Greek
mythology, the same gods,
the same pantheon
that Wonder Woman came from
Zeus is one of the people
that grant Shazam their powers.
This is canonically.
The father of Wonder Woman.
They're trying to take back one of
the sources of the Shazam family's powers.
So the whole idea is that the Shazam
name is an acronym for where they get
all their powers from all the different
gods, some of them Greek titans, not gods.
Slightly different.
Same basic mythology, though.
So the Shazam acronym stands
for The Wisdom of Solomon,
The Strength of Hercules,
the stamina of Atlas.
So that's the power that the sisters
are trying to take back, the stamina,
the power of Zeus.
That's
where their lightning bolts come from.
The courage of Achilles
in the speed of mercury.
Like the speed of mercury, for instance,
makes them almost as fast as the flash,
about as fast as Superman
is Each of the different letters
in the acronym
powers, one of their major abilities.
They can also cast
spells like a normal magician
or a normal sorcerer would be able to.
But Billy hasn't figured that out yet
because he's a little kid.
That's part of the joke of the characters.
Like he's way more powerful
than he realizes.
He just hasn't figured it out yet.
That's one of the reasons why the Wizard
Shazam gets so pissed off at him,
who they're
also bringing back in this movie,
and he looks like
a much younger version of himself,
so it'll be interesting
to see which version they say this is.
If it's like some other version
that they pulled
from a different part of the timeline,
like somehow
they captured a version of him
a long time ago in the past.
Or if this is a version
from the afterlife,
like this is the version
that died in the first movie
and they just found a way
to capture his soul.
And that's how he's come back,
because this place, their home base,
seems like a version of Mount Olympus
or near Mount Olympus,
because that's where all the Greek titans,
the Greek gods would live.
They changed a little bit of Greek
mythology just to fit this to the movie.
Like the Greek Titan Atlas did
have daughters, but they were the nymphs.
But in the movie,
they're saying it was these
three daughters
with slightly different names.
Helen Mirren is playing Hospira.
Lucy Liu is playing
someone called Calypso in.
Rachel Ziegler is playing Anthea.
So as you can see,
they're all just three different daughters
that were born during different time
periods.
Helen Mirren is the oldest sister.
Lucy Liu is the middle sister.
She's middle aged in.
Rachel Ziegler
is meant to be the youngest sister.
But I think part of the joke of that
is because of the way
they exist, like their biology.
Some of them just seem a little bit older
than the other, like Rachel Ziegler
seems like a beautiful young woman,
but she's actually really, really old.
Like Wonder Woman.
Just starting
at the beginning of the trailer footage,
Lucy Liu's
calypso comes to the Philadelphia Stadium
because remember, this is taking place
in the Philadelphia area.
She's already got the staff of the Wizard
Shazam.
Remember,
they find at the museum and they reform it
and they use that to channel
their father's power.
When they have all these moments
in the trailer where Billy talks
about giving up his powers to the sisters
so that they'll leave Philadelphia alone,
they'll stop trying to destroy the planet.
And you see all the power coursing
through him and through the staff.
It's not clear if they're saying that he's
trying to give up all of his power
or just the part of the power
that comes from the great Titan Atlas,
or they're going
to completely change all this and say that
every single bit of their power
came from the Greek Titan Atlas
instead of a bunch of different gods,
the golden apple
that she jams into the ground
to start changing
things is also from Greek mythology,
but they've changed the mythology
just a little bit.
You also see Helen
Mirren's character holding one of them.
Two golden apples appear in a bunch
of different cultures, mythologies.
But because we're talking
about the Greek mythology of the DC
Universe with Shazam and Wonder Woman,
these golden apples in particular
were from the garden of the Disparities.
Who were the mythological daughters
of the Greek Titan Atlas?
But in the movie they're saying these
three daughters were those daughters.
The actual powers of the apples
were said to grant immortality.
That was their main ability,
but it sounds like they can be used
for other things too.
Most people think of the golden Apples
because they were a big part of Hercules
famous 12 labors
that he was given to complete.
Like his part of one of them,
he had to steal the golden apples
from the secret garden where they rested,
which would have been tended
by these three sisters like their lair.
He would have had to steal
the golden apples from their lair.
Basically.
I don't think we've actually seen Hercules
inside the DC Universe,
but they did tease him
in the Marvel movies in Thor, Love
and Thunder in that Post-Credits scene.
The reason why both Marvel and DC can do
versions of the Greek pantheon
like Hercules in zoos is because there's
no copyright on those characters.
They have a bunch of scenes
back at their lair
at this place where it seems that they're
keeping the Wizard Shazam captive,
and it seems like they capture Freddie
Freeman and take him back there too.
It looks like they use the power
of the golden apples and there's a power
that they have access to already to change
Philadelphia into something more akin
to what you would have seen in Greek
mythology is history.
They cut past the Fast and Furious.
Seemed like
they had a version of this scene
in the last trailer
where he makes the Fast and Furious family
joke just because that's the whole basis
for the Shazam movies, is it?
It's about the Shazam family,
Lucius family,
Everybody posting your Vin Diesel memes.
They use this scene with her just slapping
him around just because he was clowning.
So much.
Just to let you know that she is a threat.
She does have actual power
without taking all of the power back.
Just because they want their father's
power
doesn't mean
they don't already have a lot of power.
The new version of the Warner Brothers
logo for the movie
just looks like it's etched in stone
just to make it look very ancient.
This just seems like
one of the books of magic
that they're reading that
you see Mary Marvel reading from
with a bunch of Greek mythology around it,
like a bunch of Greek artifacts,
is they're trying to figure out
what's going on with the sisters.
Part of the idea of this movie,
because there's so much of that,
they don't know, is it?
They'll just learn more
about their actual powers,
like how their actual powers work,
where they come from,
how they got them in the first place,
which gets back to the source,
like how the power came from this Greek
titan Atlas.
It's one of those situations
where people like the Wizard Shazam,
like the people who originated
a lot of the powers,
created a lot of the way the powers work,
reveals information
that he hasn't already like,
Oh, by the way,
yeah, When I gave you these powers,
I got them from a bunch of these
other places
in the places that I got them from
are now getting really pissed off
about that.
It seems like their fight with
Calypso is dragging
is a huge part of the movie,
like one of the huge action sequences
because there's so much of it
in all the trailers.
He even makes a Game of Thrones
Khaleesi reference talking about Calypso,
losing your Dragons, Khaleesi
got AJ colors.
And the other interesting thing too,
is that it seems like
even though they take Freddie
Freeman Anthea, Rachel Ziegler's character
seems like she has like some weird shit
going on with him where she actually goes
against her sisters
to try and protect him.
Like she starts siding
with the Shazam family because you see her
getting blasted by the same energy
that the sisters are giving off.
There's a real big Batman and Robin Easter
egg on Freddie Freeman's t shirt.
He was also wearing the Superman
Henry Cavill t shirt in the last movie.
He's meant to be the big Justice
League fanboy.
He's the one that also had Batman's
battering.
This t shirt also has a big Robin
reference.
Obviously, we know Robin exists
because we saw a version of him
during Batman v Superman or his suit,
but he was long since dead.
It seems kind of like a macabre
Easter egg,
but the whole idea is
that they're actual birds,
like it's a Batman bird and it's a robin
that's an actual Robin.
Ben Affleck's Batman wasn't
supposed to be featured in the movie,
but they did have a version of him
in the last trailer.
But the footage was from the Justice
League movie.
One of the planned cameos for
the movie was Wonder Woman.
There were a bunch of Wonder Woman
cameos in the upcoming films this year
that reportedly they actually deleted
because of all the re castings.
I don't know if they've gotten rid
of Wonder Woman in this movie
because she sounds like
she was a bit of a throwaway joke
the way that they used her in the movie.
So they might still let her be in it.
I think a lot of the teasers
in the post-credits scenes and things
that they got rid of in movies
like The Flash movie, for instance,
that Big Superman cameo during
that were mostly
because they were meant to set up
future movies
that they never intend on paying off now
because of all the recasting
and the rebooting.
But you see
all the other DCU footage here,
they in the trailer when he's talking
to his therapist, his child therapist,
because Billy is still technically a child
in the eyes of the law.
And he just talking to them
about how a couple of years on
since the events of the first movie,
he still feels like kind of a fraud
compared to the other Justice
League characters
in reportedly,
while he's talking to his therapist,
he talks about this fantasy
that he has about going on a date
with Wonder Woman,
and they pay that off at some point.
In a funny way, during the movie,
you know, he's wearing The Goonies t shirt
as they're activating their powers
Thematically,
their group is kind of like The Goonies.
Never say Die, a group of little kids
going on an adventure.
They just happen to have crazy powers.
This thing of Helen Mirren's character
talking about the power
being ripped from her father
seems like she's talking to Jim Enhances
Wizard.
Shazam.
The joke here with Billy
talking about writing things down
also seems like they're
in some sort of nightclub,
like there's people serving
drinks behind them and he's a little kid.
He's not supposed to be in there, like get
to be over 21 to be in a bar like that.
They'll probably a couple of scenes
like that in the movie
where he's in very adult situations,
but he's still technically a little kid.
So we just ask really awkward.
Then Billy actually tries
to give his powers back to the sisters.
One of the differences too, I'm
not sure how they're going
to explain this during the movie yet,
but in the comics,
the way that Shazam shares his powers
with the rest of the Shazam family
is that you have a bunch
of different letters
for the different acronyms
representing the different gods
and the different types of abilities
that they get from them.
Originally, when he shared his powers,
he just shared different parts
of the acronym.
But the way they change that
in the first movie,
they made it seem like the issues here
a fractional amount of the exact
same powers, like they all have access
to all the abilities there is operating
at a fractional amount of the total
amount of power available to them.
So when it seems like he's trying
to give the powers back to them,
it sounds like he's trying
to give all of the power back to them,
not just the stamina of Atlas
because of the big DC reboot.
Obviously a lot of questions
about how they're going to end this movie.
Like,
I'm not expecting them to end the movie
with Zero Power,
but there might be a big twist.
Usually in a movie like this,
they pull a Thor Ragnarok
where they recontextualize the way
their powers work,
or they find a different source
for their powers.
That's also one of the big things
about the Shazam characters.
It's the same for Black Adam too.
They can get the same power,
but from different gods,
like they can make bargains
or contracts with different gods,
so they have the same abilities.
The other thing they might wind up doing,
because it seems like Hospira,
Rachel Ziegler's character,
goes against her sisters,
is that by the end of the movie
they'll come to an agreement with them
and they'll start acting
more like the patron gods
granting their powers
to the Shazam family.
Whereas at the beginning of the movie,
they're trying to take everything back.
But in the original comics,
Shazam didn't take all the power
from like Zuse and the other Greek gods.
They were just granted access
to that power
by the gods
who were still alive at the time.
The big change in the DC Universe, though,
is that all those Greek gods
are supposed to have died a long time ago,
according to Wonder Woman.
But because we have the big James Gunn
DC Phase one reboot, obviously
a lot of that doesn't matter anymore.
Speaking of which,
Zachary Levi was seen with Peter
Safran and family posting about people
in this big reboot
and he seems very confident
that he's going to be coming back
to Shazam.
Jason Momoa
also just posted something very similar
where he seems very confident
that he's coming back
like no one is coming to take Aquaman
for me.
I will always be Aquaman.
What was your meeting with James
Gunn and Peter Safran like?
It's very, very wonderful.
I'm in the house of Warner Brothers
and that they like him a lot of stuff
I'm doing, and we got a lot of good things
going, you know, I'll always be Aquaman.
The rumors are
I'll always be like lemonade
and want to go and take
And then there might be
some other characters too, so.
Oh, so we can play.
I can play other things too.
I can be funny and savage and charming
once in a while.
The extra joke about Jason
Momoa, though, is that he also said
that he would be additional characters
on top of that too.
I've already done
like a completely separate video,
so I'll post the link at the end of this
because it sounds like he's
actually going to be playing
a version of Lobo, potentially
even more characters on top of that,
while he also plays Aquaman
at the same time in future
DC movies, it'll be fascinating
to see how they pull that off.
And because it's the end of January is me
posting this video.
James Gunn said that he would announce
the DC Phase one slate, or he's calling it
DC chapter one,
like he's calling them chapters.
So instead of DC phase one, technically
it's DC chapter one two movies,
but it's the same basic concept
of like Marvel Phase
one, Marvel, Phase two, Marvel,
Phase three.
What will probably happen
because we're so close
to the end of the month, is that
he's either
waiting till like the beginning
of next week,
like literally the end of the month,
like the last
possible minute on January 31st
or it'll be in the next couple of days.
We're literally coming down to the wire.
So of course
I'll post videos for whatever he announces
these new DC movies are going to be.
We know about the new Superman movie,
but there's still a lot of questions
about what the other ones are going to be
because the Super Bowl is coming
really soon.
The new Flash trailer
is going to drop at the Super Bowl.
There'll be a whole bunch of other
Super Bowl
trailers, too,
for Marvel, for other stuff.
Of course they'll do videos for all those.
Make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Everyone click here to listen to Jason
Momoa
talk about continuing to be Aquaman
and the other character that he's playing.
Big teaser and click here for that
brand new flash trailer.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.